My toddler woke up with a cough and a slight sore throat this morning
and when I checked the fridge
I realized we were all out of cough syrup,
so it was definitely time for a restock.
I started by peeling one lemon,
moving on to peeling a good amount of ginger.
I don't know what it is about peeling ginger,
but it's always so hard for me.
I poured some filtered water into my pot,
added my ginger, my lemon peel,
some fresh thyme, and also some lemon balm.
I usually just eyeball the ingredients,
put that on the stove to simmer for about 45 minutes
and then turn the heat off
and just let it cool down while I get started on mixing some honey
and the juice of about two small lemons.
Sometimes I do three. I squeeze them through a fine mesh strainer,
making sure that I don't get any of the seeds in.
My herbal mixture is warm and not hot anymore.
I strain that as well,
making sure to get every last drop before giving that
a really good mix and we're all done.
I usually store this in the fridge,
especially during cold and flu season,
and give them a few spoonfuls throughout the day.